[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push way
[Music]
welcome to a very special episode of
fight night flashbacks i'm here with the
man the legend matt mitrione we're going
to go over a few of your fights man now
the team has decided to kick this off
it's me a little awkward for both of us
it's you versus me in toronto ufc 165.
now i will say this going into this
fight against you
i was the most nervous i've ever been in
any fight a cause your friend b i knew
how talented you were and then also see
i don't think people realize this the
ufc offered me a six-fight extension
before this fight and i went
no i'm going to bank on myself i'm going
to fight my contract out and then force
you guys to pay me more money right it
just happened to be against this savage
named matt matron who's my friend who's
stupid athletic and then also
all my
deals for endorsements were also
predicated on me win this fight oh no so
and then i'm fighting you yeah who i
like yeah and it's in toronto it's a
nightmare yeah like i didn't want to do
it so
the amount of pressure i felt in this
fight
and then i
you know like i was very aware like all
right matt his footwork's better mine
his movement he's quick he's super
powerful
the my only intention on this fight the
entire camp was to get you down yeah
that was it dude we'll we'll talk about
let's watch the fight i'll
all right hit it
so it was it was very awkward
in here like i and this is when coming
in look how young we look to babies
children is when
i realized that
lauren lando was cornering you i didn't
know
so lauren landau uh trained matt for to
get ready for the nfl enemy yeah and
that was mine and matt's connection
going the ultimate fighter because we
both had lauren as a friend yeah so this
like so i've known lauren a long time at
this point and then i see lauren in the
hotel and i figured i knew that you and
lauren worked together um as far as like
training and helping your body stuff
like that and then i see him cornering
you and i was like this [ __ ]
right here um so it was a little bit of
like a kick on the nuts a little bit
yeah that's our boy yeah and i was like
all right don't let it affect you don't
let it affect you what's interesting too
like
you know on food truck that weird you
know you said how lorenzo was like how
could you not beat shop dude i was the
minus 110 favorite you know what i'm
saying like plus 100 which in mma is
basically a toss-up that's a coin flip
that's a pick you know what the [ __ ]
gonna happen yeah whoever lands first
whoever gets the the better of the one
early on that's how it's gonna go down i
was so got
so nervous i [ __ ] hate watching my
fights yeah anything worse than watching
your fights is watching your stand up
yeah but that's so awkward man you got
to be a complete narcissist to like
watching yourself yeah
insane do i miss prime brittany
she's still doing pretty well yeah she's
not bad yeah she's the people both of
them shout out to both of them yeah uh
yeah and i just knew your movement was
good here and i knew you're a knockout
artist so it's not like i didn't think
you're you don't want to touch clouds
you know why we're just super [ __ ] up
you know i didn't want to hurt my
feelings there i went oh wow because of
mike uh mark madison mike matson oh uh
john madison john metz yeah because of
john patterson yeah because he touched
gloves
yeah that's right yeah and that was like
i never did my whole career i never
touched gloves oh wow i thought with me
though we were friends so here i hear
your corner get him to the ground
brendan get him to the ground and i was
like oh i was like oh that's and that's
hannah gracie young get him to the
ground yeah my jiu-jitsu coach yeah
i just knew like
here's the thing though when you fight
matt matrion
like
the chances of
if you win it's gonna be by a vicious ko
so there's nothing scarier you know what
i'm saying and then your head like you
don't get knocked out you get this
[ __ ] rottweiler head
well like for for you i was like i knew
i knew you're you're long i know you're
athletic and i know that you're rangy as
far as how you use your hands so i
started getting to set up his hair and i
think i throw a low kick and i was like
okay i can hear your corner get under
the ground get on the ground i'm like
all right so be careful with what you
throw here and then i throw a body kick
here in a minute i think those kicks i'm
losing the first round or second round
uh first round okay um and i threw a
body kick and when i threw it i was like
oh i saw your face be like oh [ __ ] yeah
that hurt yeah got it and that's okay i
was like you have big legs yeah i was
like let's get back into this thing
but yeah this hero the whole time i'm
hearing get him to the ground brendan
get him out
no [ __ ] no i couldn't i was nervous i
didn't want to get taken down
uh and then my whole plan was you had
there was a headbutt there yeah you know
you had about me earlier i didn't know
no not head but we clashed heads yeah
that's no one's fault but i was bleeding
but i just knew i had to get you down
because you're about to [ __ ] fire off
literally i was like i gotta get them
down and the only way i can get them
down is by throwing high to get your to
get you my guard come up i have to yeah
so because you're too athletic your hips
are too good
you think about it like your hips are so
[ __ ] good
a standard wrestler is not going to be
able to get you down like you have to
mix it up
like even there like that's not working
yeah it's heartbreaking
um
that's not god i've never watched this
fight no i do like i don't i don't even
mean to not talk about it or during it i
just like uh no and it weird like
something yeah sometimes i'll just watch
the fights man yeah
um
you didn't get really good movement
though and i was i'm a pressure guy
right so i'm a pressure fighter so i
walk you back a lot
and you did a really good job i was
literally just waiting for you to
explode did you come in and drop under
that's all i thought about i just need
to [ __ ] commit and you're not taking
the bait yeah like that kick [ __ ] me
up that was a hard kick um yeah you did
a good job you were always you're highly
cognizant of where my feet were going to
be all the time
and then um i think i said you're the
triple threat i know you can take down
and you're throwing you're throwing good
punches and it made me have to be aware
of where my feet were i could never set
roots and try to counter punch because
if i did i was afraid it doesn't get
taken down yeah the only thing with the
punches it's literally just to keep you
busy and then faint and i was hoping you
would rush in like you've done in
previous fights they see this combo is
literally just to get you going then
yeah get you just i figured swing back
like you laughed there yeah and then
yeah i shot that's what i was like damn
i'm waiting for the laugh and that's all
i have yeah
and then you know what's what drives
even this day i actually thought about
this a handful of days ago like i'm how
did i had the unhook i got up right i
was fine and i left my head in the hole
like what in the hell was i doing at
least i think i did i like i said i
haven't watched hey you want to see
something funny mike if you rewind it a
little bit you'll see joe rogan turn
around and smile because that's me and
joe are really close especially at this
time he turned on a smile because brian
goes when i take matt down you hear
brian like yell something great like
thank god or something stupid
you'll see right you see you see rogan
right there
and then watch once i get them down
watch
watch this
watch rogan toronto just laugh watch
watch
see you
see it's all laughing yeah
the um he said he hated this fight oh
dude he hated it yeah it was
um i'm glad that nobody liked it like
because i i just was not happy about it
i'm just glad nobody got hurt oh [ __ ]
dude there's nothing worse than hurting
yeah like even if i didn't like him i
didn't want to hurt anybody yeah i'd say
it's one of my biggest downfalls as a
fighter like i didn't want to hurt you
i'm exact same way that's why like for
me like fighting mma got got hard see
like that's why i got up and i leave my
head in the hole oh you went for the
darts immediately yes i didn't know that
i thought i was more up no that's all i
wanted oh they were telling you to think
you could get up so i told my kids
they're like so i gave a thumbs up here
do you know this yes i gave it to you
like you're good yeah
and then i don't think there's no how
the [ __ ] is he good i kept doing this to
levar johnson because his shoulder was
so
muscular because on steroids i couldn't
[ __ ] choke him out
[Laughter]
dude the most satisfying win i've ever
had my kids were like my kids are like
daddy's like why didn't you tap and i
was like because i didn't [ __ ] quit
yeah i was like he got me in a spot like
i knew i was i knew i was probably gonna
lose at the moment and i was like well
[ __ ] it so i gave a thumbs up and i was
like whatever by the way rudy's the best
rapper hand wrap in the entire game the
best the best hands down i was so
[ __ ] relieved man yeah you're such a
monster yeah that [ __ ] was not fun um
that was terrible man yeah and then once
that once that was over i think i came
too and i was looking at the lights and
i was like yeah i don't think i could
you know wait look at i mean
you were boys man we were boys in the
back yeah i was so [ __ ] somebody came
up and told me like he just ate a
[ __ ] burrito right before the fight
and i was like what
yeah yeah
because i couldn't i couldn't eat the
day of the fight yeah i could like two
weeks two days before i can eat and then
lauren land i was like dude you have to
have energy yeah
if this fight goes in the third round
you'll be [ __ ] yeah so he made sure
that energy yeah dude so i i never like
you know what you hit a darts on
somebody before or something and i never
practiced defense two doors ever yeah
like i don't know like it was weird like
i was down in florida like and i just
and after the fight was over i was like
how did i never practice that like how
did i made me re-change i guess i got i
got damiko rogers and anaconda but other
than that not a lot but remember going
was that lavar did you do before i got a
did you find him before me yeah
what it was yeah and i kept doing on but
he was so his shoulders were so [ __ ]
big yeah i couldn't he was punching you
in it yeah yeah and he kept going you're
a [ __ ] man won't we get up and bang i'm
like once you learn jujitsu
yeah what are you doing shut up he's
actually nice to me i know he's in
prison yeah he uh does he write you
letters
i wish but i thought because he was in a
biker gang like i don't was he really
yeah like straight up enforcing the bike
thing
my
so we're at the bar in the hotel and the
levar johnson walks in with his biker
gang yeah and i hit my brother hey get
ready to go man right these are these
guys the real deal and i was so nervous
yeah and then levara's team came around
me they circled around like i'm gonna
shank man this is how i go right i
should have let him win i [ __ ] i'm an
idiot and then they go our boy needs to
learn how to grapple huh i'm like yeah
yeah no doubt i'm like dude great job
man i was like oh you guys are great oh
[ __ ] they're great i was so nervous
there's a dude
that fought in bellator i don't think he
fights for him anymore i can't remember
his name
but he's like a hell's angel and he like
had like a hell's angel patch on his
shorts it's so insane for sure no one's
more insane than a [ __ ] hip man oh
who couldn't come to the states because
he's busy yeah rob rotten how crazy is
that dude
so the next fight we have here uh thank
god we got through that fight with you
no [ __ ] that was [ __ ] awkward yeah uh
we got matt matron derek lewis dude this
has to be when you look back on your
career and your kids are older and
they're talking about your fights this
has to be one you bring up because you
have
derek lewis hall of famer i don't know
if i'll ever win the title i don't know
you know the the mma is weird but
you're talking about a guy who has the
most knockout that heavyweight you're
talking about a real [ __ ] he knocks
everybody out he's scared
um and do you know him at all like
really good dude no i don't know i've
talked to him after this fight i had him
on the show
really i had him on the show he seemed
like a a good
patient casual dude such a good dude
smaller than i thought that figures me
huge but at least he actually wasn't
that big but then uh he's like you know
i hate losing man like yeah i hear you
mean no no not because different reasons
he goes i have like four kids man and
when i come home they make fun of me
he's like and i can't stand it it's so
embarrassing man for like two weeks is
the running joke in the house right he's
like so i'm just winning so they don't
make fun of me
all right dude everybody's got their
motivation so this fight like i don't
know we're talking about the beer i
don't know what the odds are
are we are we we got some whiskey you
want something tiger's thick whiskey
that's good it's my whiskey dog is it
really yup you have your own whiskey
yeah man what i don't know where did
this start happening uh you know we're
just launching nationwide why did you
tell me this before to drink this the
whole time i don't know you love those
bears man
i mean we have all sorts of [ __ ] yeah
give some ice with a cup let me pull a
little smell like that go ahead doug
it's nice little japanese
yeah japanese whiskey with american
bourbon yeah yeah man it's nice smooth i
mean
why are you keeping secrets over here i
don't know hey man i had the best old
fashioned in my entire life out in vegas
this weekend old fashioned two weekends
ago i don't like [ __ ] my drinks just
straight i only drink it straight man
okay but where'd you have it at it was
at the
the top floor bar
on
resort world it was nice like a
panoramic kind of yeah
that was nice bar
yeah actually we uh we just went just
just uh for no reason whatsoever um and
then uh hung out chilled had a great
time and it was really dope and it was
an old fashioned made with
black
johnny johnny walker black
scotch
uh yeah um channel worker black
orange simple syrup they feel like they
peel that orange and make simple syrup
and use it cook it down in there some
bitters and
some kind of cherry liqueur it was nice
just a little bit it was the smoothest
drink of how much you have ever had uh
probably had four
tacos
so this is so so this is this is a 25
foot cage i [ __ ] hate the 25 location
you should only fight in big cages
that's it dude you and derek lewis well
it should be a 50-foot cage like for
matt but also
this limits your athletic that's [ __ ]
good is it nice smooth doug thank you
man um this limits your athletic ability
because
what makes you special is your footwork
and explosiveness same with like winter
boy thompson she should never fight in a
small cage never because then it's such
an advance for the other opponent derek
lewis yeah bro he footwork what are we
talking about he's just trying to land
that huge [ __ ] right hand to get you
against the wall and then correct my
whole entire world around if he gets you
down his ground back so um
that's one of the biggest things i had
against the ufc is that they never told
you what size cage you were fighting in
until you got there let me ask you so
who's the main event
smaller guys
because usually off the minivan
it's
ben rothwell and overing oh the biggest
guys so that makes even less sense i
think it's ben rothwen over him wow
because i know i i won the one that that
overeem lost on and then i was like all
right ben i'm going to see you soon
because i wanted to choke him down
ben knocked him out didn't he they've
been choking
savage dude i'm surprised you guys never
up we did we did and i was whipping his
ass and i got lost in the first round
and then i got so cocky i was like i'm
going to take this [ __ ] down and
beat him in his own game got caught
attempting a joke that [ __ ]
that's right that's when he's like he
kept ten finger choking everyone me and
josh marnette that's right josh barnett
dude savage [ __ ] love him he's like a
mentor mine like josh and i are talking
he's one of my favorite people we don't
know each other i [ __ ] love you he's
a [ __ ] gangster he's also i think as
far as iq wise like has to be highest of
all time like in the ufc dude he's so
smart so smart he is whiskey too shout
out to you so josh barnett oh you know i
can reach out to him now that we're here
um
there was
the first time i went to go train with
him he was like i remember your training
with him yeah and i got told by people
people don't train with him don't he's
going to hurt you don't train with him
he's an [ __ ] [ __ ] him that was the
rumor for everyone
so then
i go train with him right him and er i
go to eric paulsen josh is there that's
part of the reason i go to eric paul
paulsen because josh um and then josh
wasn't there or something like the first
couple days and then he comes in and
then we're doing some work and we're
we're doing some stand-up stuff we're
doing some grappling stuff we're doing
some take down stuff whatever else and
we're probably training for about 45
minutes to an hour and then he does
something catches me in probably a dark
some kind of choke yeah catches me in it
i tap holds it i tap i hold it
i go to sleep
okay
so i wake up
and i think he wanted to see how i
responded to it like to see if i was
gonna be a [ __ ] and kind of pop off a
little bit or if i was gonna be like
yeah let's go keep going yeah so i woke
up and i go
okay that's your one
and then i didn't trip i didn't i didn't
pop off on it at all and then ever since
then you guys were cool that
[ __ ] let me drill on him he lets
me do everything like
when i would train with him he would
literally be my practice dummy he would
do whatever he would give me positions
he would lay on the ground let me put
pressure on him do anything he didn't
care what's happening
dude he was so dope he was such a good
dude to me that it's it's shocking
that's awesome when he went to bellator
they tried to get me to fight josh and
josh was like absolutely not total
bellator absolutely not i was in a spot
where i couldn't turn down fights if i
turn down fights can extend my contract
um and josh was like
i'm saying no there's no chance he has
that leverage he can say
he's a [ __ ] gangster he's so cool
dude he's been so good to me the entire
time great i should get him in here dude
he's got hell of a story too man i know
great all the stories let's take a
little break from chat with my boy matt
matrione about all the big fights in his
life so i got something to tell you man
if you watch any show that i do you see
me on stage in la at the comedy story
improv you see me on tour the thick boy
tour
there's one thing that i'm always doing
and i use kratom i swear by kratom i use
kratom i use it every day and i can't
emphasize enough it's my limitless pill
you've seen bradley cooper do his thing
that's the closest that i can get to a
limitless pill that's kratom but
kratom's the wild west right now man it
is remember cbd a few years ago
everyone's like it sounds good but is
this stuff real that's where kratom is
right now in thailand they've used it
for thousands of years so if you want to
try it you want to fire up that brain
man you got to use a company that you
trust all right you want to be focused
for work your workouts maybe your
stand-up comic maybe your podcaster
maybe just the dad you want to focus in
you gotta trust happy hippo herbal.com
use the promo code sickboy for 20 off
for life this is a one time deal load on
up use it man that is happy hippo
herbal.com promo code sickboy for 20 off
for life the best kratom you can trust
this kratom i use the shots you can
trust happy
hippo herbal.com promo code sickboy 20
off let's get back to the show yeah all
right let's watch your derrick lewis
fight with you soon so i hate being in
the smoke cage and then i'm in there and
i'm thinking myself
young you look our faces were way
slimmer back in the day huh you know but
i think where else's
again here lack of respect from vegas
yeah but obviously you know you are
fighting it
not a great fight well i here's the
thing though you break this fight down
like your footwork you're so much more
elusive so i guess the odd makers are
banking on him landing one
mario you know if you get hit he's just
gonna let him you're gonna let it go
um
so what's what city is this in this is
in connecticut
it's in connecticut and
he told i told him he called me up by
name because he beat one of my teammates
guto innocent uh brazilian dude and he
called me out by name because i was
supposed to fight struve in 175. and
struve had that the heart thing heart
issue yeah and i told him i was like i'm
going to stand over your unconscious
body for saying my name out loud so
aggressive um
and i knew right now i could tell they
didn't like pressure right he wasn't
used to being somebody being he's not
started for the most part is he i i
would say so like he has he has those
knockouts but yeah it takes him a while
to get going
so i could tell when i first came at him
and he he ducked under i was like okay
he's gonna be looking for a takedown oh
now it's almost like it's almost like a
forearm shiver you know if you rewind it
you'll see that i'm sure they showed him
starting to throw a straight teen off
and that's why i stood over his body oh
wow talk [ __ ] to him yeah i told you i
was his team upset what happened
um no they didn't say [ __ ]
i mean that one of your best wins by
fargo yeah and it's not like you got
lucky like you [ __ ]
yeah you know why you know what's
interesting look at you it's how you
look at you um
football
how football
translates to sports sometimes
where when you see
i throw that straight and i convert it
to another cut and he starts getting
ready to throw that overhand right
my hips
engage and i shuck him off as in like he
has no linemen yes and i'm shucking off
the block you can make a tackle yeah so
see it in a second you'll see it here
um and watch how my body doesn't move it
is a right hook and then you throw it
and so my body never moves backwards my
hips absorbed it yeah and threw it out
and he wasn't used to that power no no
and that's the translation of football
from your hips and now i see it
sometimes i'm like oh man no [ __ ] yeah i
was also really surprised that i didn't
knock him out because i was in the first
one banging on that cat dude the first
punch like when once i dropped him right
like i boop and he fell down i came in
with the right hand dude i swear to god
i felt like i hit him with a shovel i
mean my hand was like big it was like a
home run punch you know and you get in
your head you're like oh he's different
he's dead yeah no i killed a guy yeah
matt kill again
so this next fight now don't get a twist
here fedor is 36 and four son so 40
fights you have 16. your 16's not [ __ ]
to him he had that when he was like 18.
yeah so they give you fedor i'm actually
working this fight
and uh this is a scary one man when you
think about it i mean i know you don't
know who he is i can't say his last name
but it's like
you you're literally like there's three
goats in this world and it's [ __ ]
fedor's on everybody's list yeah to me
it's like
it would be you know stipe
fedor and uh you put steeping in the
goats
for a heavyweight hundred percent yeah
but to me came to me a prime came before
the injuries a prime king beats all of
these guys
nobody was better than kane in his prime
you think you think kane would have been
fedor in prime a hundred percent
molly whopped them
wore his ass out to me like when i was
watching the tape like kane and his
prime there's never a better heavyweight
that's ever existed on the planet
you talked to dc about it you know who's
heavyweight champ like heavyweight champ
and he trained with him in his prime
he's like you've you've never seen
anything like him man so he's like he
beat the [ __ ] out of all of us tell
mccain-wise yes so uh my buddy i don't
know if you guys are friends luke
rockhold love luke yeah that's my buddy
[ __ ] love the dude um best looking
guy to ever fight in this for sure 100
percent and he's a [ __ ] gangster too
yeah yeah grappling is [ __ ] off the
charts like stupid he's how you know
yeah if you've been out of california
you probably seen it quite a bit i've
seen down in florida or he was grabbing
some world level dudes he didn't know
who the it's like me with fighting
didn't know who the [ __ ] they were and
he was [ __ ] watching crushing them
that's what bothers me about like what
like with john blockbuster i'm like
grapple dude like you're you're
grappling is better than anything right
and that's saying a lot because he's a
[ __ ] savage striker yeah like his
grappling
world class right yonder he's just done
[ __ ] luke no luke yeah but he just
doesn't he like donned he put a gee on a
couple times and one purple belt walls
he's afraid
worlds purple world worlds whatever it
is so here you are with fedor uh did you
feel pressure in this fight you didn't
give a [ __ ] because it was legendary i
was i was i was getting i was getting
paid the most ever got paid up to that
point so my thoughts were like [ __ ] it
man i'm about to make some money here we
are yeah um and it was like in the
opposite part of all the trump stuff um
like the trump and putin stuff it was in
madison square garden uh it was like it
was a perfect mixture did you walk out
to like bruce springsteen or something
a simple man that's always your [ __ ] i
do i cannot hear simple man without
thinking of you you know what's funny
it's your [ __ ] uh
my first fight against
kimbo i think mike brown from american
top team was on that same card and
whoever it was that handles the music
called me up about a week before and was
like hey there's two people in the car
that are playing simple man and i was
like who's the other guy and he's like
mike brown i was like okay well i by
this time i knew who mike brown was and
i was like all right well if let me let
me get mike's number so i call mike and
i'm like hey man how do you feel about
me having this song he's like listen i'm
in the honor cards you're a main event
he's her main card he's like so you are
like don't you if you want to use that
song he's like you use it i'm not a
legend dude
i know he's talking about the name
legend a lot but mike brown's up [ __ ]
for sure yeah
and he was like he's like listen man
he's like i'll be honest with you he's
like he's like if you want to use that
song from now on he's like i'd be
honored if you carry that tradition oh
wow i think i really appreciate it why
did you pick that song um
because i felt like it it represents me
as a human being that's so fair i hear
that song and all i do is think about
you yeah um i have with my pants up
obviously
like there's a lot about that song i
felt like always
touched my soul it has enough enough
enough soul to it and it's like hey man
don't don't get big for your [ __ ] and
it's not like really intense like you
walk out and you're kind of you sing
along with it it fits your vibe yeah so
he came out to that song and fedor came
out to his
something dope it was something good
really it wasn't like the russian anthem
that might be what it i don't think it
was he comes out some like i thought he
came into like russian opera or
something something yeah yeah yeah
whatever it was it's scary it was
powerful yeah it's scary and you know
his brother was like you know yeah so i
taught hershey i heard that's what got
him into fighting was
some issues that alexander got into and
that's how fader got into it that's what
i'm talking about best friends putin
dude i bet you
vader has so much respect for you he
talked even now he talks about he wanted
to end his career on fighting you like
last week he said that did he really
yeah i would say i'd love to get that
fight back yeah i'd love to fight i told
them
do it in moscow that's what i wanted but
they would like definitely bring your
wife because she's here i'd want to say
this but dude think about fedor
putin russia
in a private
private mma show for putin and like the
the russian government and it was it was
it was paid x amount of money and they
were like hey will you do it blah blah
and he's like he fought like
he didn't do it he didn't do it because
something came up and i don't think who
did they offer this to i don't want to
say his name somebody we know for sure
somebody i know very very very very well
very very well you know who he is
and they offered him
they offered him money to uh this
situation to go over and fight in a
private mma show and it was like six six
fights like so it was like 12 people on
the card oh this this you you referring
to this the movie plot lying lionheart
with van damme whatever
yeah in russia
so so i wanted to wear jeans dude
[ __ ] whatever whatever it would be
yeah absolutely
and it's i'm sure it's a two minute
one-man league and he it ended up not
happening anybody told me i was like
dude [ __ ] do it i was like do it i'll
[ __ ] well they're gonna hear this and
offer it to you dude i don't know if you
wanna do that right now cause we have to
invade ukraine yeah after that but um
this whole situation of of this fight
here uh
i told them was like i told fedor as
soon as this fight was over i was like
hey if you ever if you ever want to run
it back yes
just i'm telling you that's what i think
all you did was say my name was like my
retirement fight i'd love to get that
fight back against
mma again for him oh wow breaking news
yes but it's like with federal you would
fight mma again for him no no absolutely
not no oh get the [ __ ] i swear to god i
wouldn't no i wouldn't that's how good
life is i'm telling you i would not
i mean yeah i'd go to russia and corner
you because i want to go to russia but
only if like putin's cool you know what
i'm saying like no shade on putin
if they're like if putin's like i love
shop i'd be like oh say less i'll warn
you and go out there um i think i'd be
insane if hey fedor i know you're
watching
if you want i know you want to fight me
i will 100 say yes
obviously bellator won't be part of it
uh
but uh if you want to scrap me in russia
but it's got to be in moscow or well you
say i don't care if it's in a barn don't
care if it's in the in the middle of
snow or blizzard he has the means to do
it like yeah he didn't
he didn't obey by the military rules
it's yeah it's whatever he's like i'm
gonna fight putin's gonna put the
promotion on mom fight matt 100
everybody in russia i wouldn't dude i
would you know this was i do i would
fight him tomorrow if he was like a man
but why beat him it doesn't matter
money-wise it doesn't matter like legacy
like why just because it's such a
[ __ ] rush it's so i have no desire to
do that yeah no there's not a man on
this earth that i don't want to fight i
don't i don't i don't like fighting but
i'm addicted to the drug you like the
the rush i'm addicted to the drugs i'm
addicted to competition
i know we got to find that for you
outside of your punch in the face yeah
maybe it's that cooking show whatever it
is i don't know if that's going to get
your rocks off but maybe it will maybe
if you see a million views on youtube
you're like yeah this is similar to
fighting fedor in russia
probably not though huh all right let's
hit it
yeah this fight was stressful man so i
was sitting across here i was standing
across here and i was thinking i was
like man he
really does look like a cabbage patch
kid like that's weird yeah is that weird
you're talking about the goat and he
just you know let's be honest he's not
gonna win any bodybuilding contest he's
slapping his tummy he's always in those
you know he was slapping himself and his
everything was turning red right
afterwards like well that's weird
like i was like why did he get so red
like you weren't
intimidated at all
no because like his demeanor is like
it's like a circle it's like ted bundy
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] dude yeah
like his i bet you've checked his blood
pressure doesn't even go up he's so
stoic i mean dude like there's nothing
about him and any anytime i've ever met
him that has been anything more than hey
what's up man but he's cool he's polite
yeah he speaks english way better than
anybody really he just pretends yeah
you're seeing his paintings that he
sells no yeah he paints really yeah dude
is this like they're awful is this like
people
my five-year-old does better but he
[ __ ] hustles his paintings it's good
for him dude look at that dude so let's
beat our love skins prime cro crop in
his prime mark hunt big nog tim sylvia
mark coleman kevin randleman that kevin
randleman [ __ ] fight dude was that
slam oh my god dude did you watch any of
that going into this fighter no no
no because it [ __ ] when i fought crow
cop i watched all his vintage stuff
because in my head i wanted to put that
monster that that's what i was getting
yeah and out there i'm like this ain't
that monster really yeah
see i feel like that'd be dangerous
because i'd be i'd lower myself into a
false insecurity like oh he's not the
one he used to be [ __ ] it i can chill a
little bit and that would wouldn't be as
as dialed in that's smart
yeah this fight is quick so when we get
in this situation here um he's like you
actually shake hands and i don't do [ __ ]
because he didn't do [ __ ] and once he
put his hand out he's like all right
cool sounds good
dude yeah he's basically the president
of russia let's be honest
yeah yeah there you go you didn't do
that with me whatever
you do with a russian but that's fine it
is fedor but anybody else that benefits
you know the weirdest part was being on
on the billboard at madison square
garden that was the weird part hey tito
again would you think about that you're
on the billboard at mass square garden
when we're in the ultimate fighter house
dude never if we're in the room fighter
house since then went hey what are you
16 morons it's gonna be fedor in here
i'd be like i think it might be me yeah
you know what i'm like yeah it's either
me or roy it was [ __ ] you dude
like he had good is he look at him he
has good pressure and you're moving
right you're trying to bait his ass into
a gunfight yeah i just want to see just
want to see what he's going to do
i think it's your biggest asset is your
you have that wilder that you have that
[ __ ]
that you know you have
i'm trying to reach under see if he
pulls his hand down i want to try to i'm
trying to look for the setup you're a
madman yeah you just have that no [ __ ]
given gene in your body that a lot of
guys don't have
i see i like how see i just saw that he
respected my power right so i so i moved
back uh and now i see where he's at and
i know that we're going to do the dance
in the middle he's not going to be he's
not going to be soft and bail out no
you're not going to back a russian up
yeah yeah yeah you know that um
especially fedor yeah
i think
but you both do you have so much power
and then it's just off to the [ __ ]
races like once you commit it's [ __ ]
on i knew i'm telling you it's just
you're the one that engages you know
he's so quick dude even to this day
i love how it just rides out those tiny
shorts even though it's like oh my god
dude and then you your athleticism
was a fight
i saw his head hit the canvas and as
soon as i saw his head of the camera
it's like finish him but like my brain
was if you don't finish him now you're
fine
you're [ __ ] like he's too good to [ __ ]
around with 100 percent he's too much
look at you paying respects even though
you don't know who he is
look man that rushing i was quick ah
that's weird man that's weird how many
fights you have yeah
um
yeah it's like you have that like you
know like rip from [ __ ] yellowstone
you have this weird gene where it's just
like you don't give a [ __ ] how good is
that show huh the best [ __ ] crazy did
you watch in 1883 um i don't know but we
caught up on 1883 or we missed not
you're missing out yeah it fills the
void for yellowstone yeah same director
same right we just
two days ago i think we just watched the
last the two most recent ones um
i don't want to do any spoilers but like
on yellowstone yeah spoilers dude season
four is over man spoil it no no i
watched it when it came out it's not
over is it yeah [ __ ] yeah it's over dude
they're talking about season five now
what are you talking about you talking
about rip what are you talking about
john dutton what do you want to talk
about wait hold on a minute so so
let me hey yeah the season's been on
which one
no the one with the daughter
how uh jamie
jamie and the daughter yes that's the
last one we just watched that one just
came out didn't it no man this season's
been over for real i finished it like
three months ago i don't know i thought
it just you guys watch on parents
[Music]
just came out
so look so so i throw a little just a
little it was it was a measurement it's
not your full power just a temperature
check um and it would you know what got
you out of this uh you know it's like
your athleticism yeah for sure the key
it was muscle memory right i certainly
hit my butt is that getting from a cut
block i just hopped up and hopped right
back up and it's what paid off you both
dropped and then you popped way faster
yeah oh it was muscle memory like my
body had no choice no you were going to
do that by the way i had a sponsor in
there for 35 000
for a brand new jeep and he bailed on me
why yeah like but on my back left pocket
right there he was gonna give you a jeep
wrangler yeah that was like he just
didn't give it to you and he was like
hey thanks putting me on your shorts
what happened
was the contract
um it was a handshake
but i had done something before and he
would in before would he pay you no and
this time he's like sorry man yeah cool
man
is he from in your hometown
no no where's he at
florida yeah i can't trust florida yeah
and and and yeah dude it was and i was
like really that's
i couldn't do anything he's like all
right you know what noted yep no dude
yeah i'm not gonna put you on my shorts
yeah
he's like yeah all right i'm gonna keep
the jeep dude
thanks for putting me on your shirt
you know after spending all this time
with you on food truck and
fight night flashbacks i've realized
you're a bad negotiator
so look nothing's ever worked out so
i tried my ass off hey lorenzo
this jersey here literally got thrown
into the cage i have no idea who's a
giants jersey yeah giant it was my giant
jersey like what it was like it was like
something somebody laughed somebody's
wearing it and then i found out later on
it was a dude i know threw it in there
his name's damian damon tudelic that's
[ __ ] done and i was like no [ __ ] all
sundays give it to me i have it in my
house still that's so i mean what a
moment man right my name is jersey
you're fighting mass square garden yeah
like when you're fighting for the giants
someone's like hey dude you're going to
knock out fate or someone would say the
greatest of all time right at mass
square garden you'd be like get the [ __ ]
yeah and you're going to wear your
jersey how nuts is that i do that right
did you have a lot of support from the
your old teammates and stuff do they
realize like what you achieved here um
no
no i think a lot of them were shocked
you have no idea yeah which then again i
really didn't know what i did either
fair point um do you think this is your
biggest one in your career
yeah
it's got to be like i talk about my crow
crop fight once a week you know you know
what i would you know i would i would
say honestly it's probably my biggest
my biggest um
victory of
of my career derrick lewis no
um marcus jones
that's what set everything up yeah
because i was
i was so anxious about it because i i
wanted to fight him and i didn't want to
be emotional it was the first one i ever
really did they they played the wrong
walkout song it was like a whole mental
checklist of stuff that like
you got to get this get this under
control and then like like he had me he
had me in the guillotine right and i
just learned the the defense i used for
a guillotine like five days before yeah
and like because i saw somebody else do
it like oh that might work and then i
did it and it worked and i gave a thumbs
up again jesus and like so like that was
like the like in my opinion like that
was my biggest victory like cool some
other stuff happened and awesome but
like
like he was the one i wanted to knock
out because i had a beef with him from
the jump i was supposed to fight him
from the jungle you guys didn't like
each other yeah i felt like he was a
nice remember because because he had the
spider and i was making fun of him for
something and then he got his feelings
hurt whatever yeah and then he yeah and
then he had like an injury yeah you guys
almost fought each other on the show
remember when he was all fired up after
i beat junk yeah that's right that's
right i had to separate you guys yeah
and i was like i was like dude this dude
for real cause i knew i was so close i
think i couldn't punch him so i was
gonna be in the back do you think there
was a riff there because your guy's nfl
background like and you're like i'm the
nfl guy
he like compared to us he was a super
nfl guy he was first pick he tackled
berries
you know what drives me nuts dude
i have an autographed picture of barry
sanders he made to me i met him he gave
me a picture like we were talking about
something and my kids don't give a
single [ __ ] about it they have no idea
who yeah like it's [ __ ] barry sanders
cool bro they don't give away i'm like
hey watch this youtuber play this video
game what the [ __ ] i know i know man
like hey mr beast gives out eight
billion dollars a year dad
what the [ __ ] is mr b you've seen barry
sanders when he played for oklahoma
state little bastards
i do not like respect by the way i used
to have a a barry sanders uh oklahoma
state jersey and i had oh you're a super
fan and i had um
uh bo jackson uh burn jersey
and i was like i can't work oh you're
just a huge barry sanders fan marcus
jones tackled him you hate him for that
that's what it was i'm jealous
you know what the hardest runner in the
nfl was for me
christian mccoy wanted work done
smaller man yeah i thought he i trust
you back then i thought he broke my damn
arm with his helmet oh you're talking
about from your personal experience
awesome
i was like oh my god oh really
i never played against mike i don't know
he's a great dude by the way so we're in
we're in chicago [ __ ] up drunk as [ __ ]
rowdy is a [ __ ] i expect that on
mike i know so kayla and i
[ __ ] up in chicago having a great time
drunk and [ __ ] in a bar called happy
camper
somebody comes in and just [ __ ]
gorilla hugs me squeezes the [ __ ] and
they're like oh my god turn around and
[ __ ] all-star out of nowhere in the
same bar that we're in he's like you
[ __ ] picks me up [ __ ] you guys
know each other yeah yeah from from well
so i didn't know him at purdue right and
then we got to know him he's a purdue
group yeah you're a [ __ ] purdue guy
yeah so um i i'll be honest i was
actually
trying to get you a michael stop purdue
jersey that was going to be science
because i told you they're going to get
you something oh that's right i was
trying to get you one i was like
i was like but he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about mike he's going to give [ __ ] about
i love mike all right well then that'll
be my game that'd be my gift to you dude
i'll frame it because i was trying to
get before you because
but i was like i'm gonna get you
something and i was like dude [ __ ]
all-star purdue jersey is like i want to
get something oh i would have freaked
out i thought that had been great yeah
kind of ruined the show now that you
didn't break yeah yeah
completely down there but that's my
thing oh that'd be fun
and he's [ __ ] dope he's a great dude
man a whole famous dude he's so [ __ ]
cool
i don't know my short writing i gotta
tell you the story about this
[ __ ] so um
warren sapp i [ __ ] hate warren sapp
right oh wow the reason okay go go ahead
no you i mean you hate marcus jones
[ __ ] hate roy nelson so warren says
so
we were we were in
the first sporting event of the
millennium the outback bowl in 2000
january 1st 2000 um and we were playing
georgia 22 years ago yeah for sure
holding this grudge right so um i'm
supposed i was like uh i don't know i
was supposed to make an all-american or
something i was i was doing well i was
gonna i was gonna leave early from
college um
yeah killing it at least i thought it
was and then i was supposed to do a
video like an instructional video with
warren sapp and it was like through
purdue and he's
sap at the time he's he's more sap
defensively and so we go like
all of us snuck out and went to a bar
and warren and a couple handful of the
dudes winky wright was there half of
other dudes blah blah blah um
and i see one i'm like hey man i'm
supposed to do a video with you tomorrow
blah blah and i take my hand out
introduce myself and he goes
you done yet stupid and turned around
and walked away
and i was i was so [ __ ] offended well
i mean oh see
here's my thing marcus jones i don't get
the grudge yeah roy i don't get the
grudge warren zapp i get dude are you
done yet stupid stupid oh i was so
[ __ ] mad
yeah so then i was like if i swear to
god i've ever seen that [ __ ]
getting a spit in his mouth [ __ ] him but
that's my move like oh [ __ ] that man
yeah because [ __ ] you some people make a
lot of money
so um sounds furious i just knock out
[Music]
i just knock out sean jordan in china
who's also a freak in macau now jordan
lsu full pack full back [ __ ] national
champ
so i'm walking out um and you know and
you know i fight everything's a blur
right yeah there's people everywhere
blah blah blah and i'm walking out and
blah blah blah and somebody grabs my
hand goes hey great [ __ ] job meathead
and it's [ __ ] war and sap and i was
like and i was like in the moment right
it's like i i didn't it didn't register
oh wow
i saw it yeah it was my moment to get
that knocked him out yeah cause i
couldn't
can you imagine he's like
congratulations thank you yeah stupid
stupid like not got one sound and then
we got backstage i was like that
[ __ ] got me i was so mad she
tried going back out there and then i
saw him later on i was like hey i gotta
tell you something blah blah and then
he's like dude he's like i'm sorry i
shouldn't have ever done that i'm sorry
yeah no [ __ ] then i was talking to
allstate about him
and i was like i gotta tell you the
story about your boy warren sachs two
pro ballers two hall of famers teammates
forever right and he goes um once the
leader of the offense wins the leader
defense 100 percent yeah and mike is a
quiet leader warren's obviously the
vocal leader right yeah so um he's like
he's like so when we first came in
he signed an autograph for me and it was
like to the best to the best
white boy or something like that
warrants that sure and he said that by
the time he got done
the autograph he signed when mike
retired was to the best football player
i've ever met oh [ __ ] and he goes he
said that
warren is an [ __ ] but he's used to
people
using him
so the juice that he gives you is only
if you if you deserve it if you earn it
and that's what he's like that's the way
he'll treat everybody until you deserve
his respect his perspective i get it a
little bit i can be empathetic to a
point right but i was a colleague super
offensive though right oh yeah for sure
but like i talked to him afterwards he's
like you guys are cool yeah we're cool
now so i see him i'm not going to spend
this i mean if you and warren sap had a
podcast together they would [ __ ]
crush he's good on the mic too oh i bet
he is he's been on burke chrysler's show
he's a monster has he really yeah so i
hear he's not a bad dude at all but i
was like why the [ __ ] you in macau he's
like i was just here man weird
macau
my takeaway from this is how much of a
badass mike alstott is dude he's my
favorite he's such a he's so he's so
cool and he's a great dad too
like his son griffin griffin's a great
dude mike's a great dude across the
board how many kids do you have
two i think he has griffin and i think
he's a daughter right baby has a
daughter right
it's [ __ ] huge too griffin griffin
was a quarterback at purdue
griffin's quarterback but had a shoulder
issue and then purdue was like hey
listen man that's a fullback that's
probably not a quarterback i'm not going
to run you as a quarterback you want to
move the linebacker do something else
and he's like nah [ __ ] it i'll transfer
and transferred to like central michigan
or something like that are you still
involved with purdue mike no you yeah
so like alumni and all that yeah but
like i was helping them with like a lot
of uh like uh hip work like rotational
flexibility stuff like a lot of wall
work a lot a bunch of other stuff like
that they have that stud receiver yeah
uh david superstar and george carloftus
george koloftis dates my niece kaya and
they've been together since high school
oh wow um and so like so i worked a lot
with georgia as far as rotational
flexibility like you know what really i
found works really well for football
players um is wall work
like reversing position on a wall
because the hips like changing their
hips yeah you leverage you change your
hips you have to work around on tight
surgery that's dope your arm has to come
up right when you're finishing a rip
yeah all of it so i found wall work is
really good for defensive linemen
getting into position well that's dope
like reversing spots from being on the
wall to being out and then they have to
neutralize your hips by running along
your position right and it's it's great
for them so you work your work your work
yeah that's still man yeah so you do
that stuff
well again this could be a nine hour
podcast they're giving me the light yeah
sorry about that no we dude that's what
happens we don't see each other dude i
[ __ ] love you man i don't need to see
you bro i know dude we're busy you got
kids you gotta get a [ __ ] hot girl
it's cool your ears look good though you
think yeah
oh dude you know there's a new technique
on that what do you mean so if you get
your cauliflower now right yeah they'll
drain it and then they stitch one stitch
in it because it holds it together ain't
gonna do [ __ ] dude
dude no they didn't do that it looks
like a [ __ ] tortellini hey but it's
sexy though thanks dude is that is that
dent from where the stitch was uh
probably my ears are [ __ ] nightmare
how do you hear what
that was good thanks man all right guys
that material a little bit of work
minute don't scare us i get up i go hard
like i'm george harris make plays break
lanes push weight break chains go hard
kick ass